welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder dropped a
trailer finally we didn't know if we
were gonna get one before multiverse of
madness but here it is and you know the
drill i'm gonna react to it probably
overreact to it a bit then give you some
initial first impressions and then
tomorrow will be my in-depth frame by
frame breakdown of this bad boy but
let's give it a look-see here we
go
very simba montage
who is he planting it
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
oh love uh they're using it we're
probably gonna have to drop this audio
so we don't get flagged but um i mean
they should have used the adam scott
version from step brothers
i'm
loving the look of this it's so colorful
whoa
i love it
zeus confirmed
wait that's straight from um
that's from the comics i've seen that
before
political turmoil
[Laughter]
not me
just listening
oh that's it
okay
oh damn
[Music]
whoa
okay all right so we get the jane foster
reveal no gore the god butcher yet just
some evidence of his crimes interesting
move i gotta say because obviously
seeing christian bale in that look
hearing his voice seeing his weapon is
obviously uh the big question at the
moment and while i would have loved to
get this teaser way earlier i am someone
who prefers trailers to just give us a
sense of the tone in the vibe of a movie
as opposed to putting all the big
reveals and spoilers in the trailer like
one of my favorite thought experiments
with thor ragnarok is to go back and
look at that movie if hulk was not in
the first trailer and if we had no idea
that hulk was gonna be in that movie
what an insane surprise it would have
been to see him burst into that
gladiator arena obviously i love the
song choice of this trailer guns n roses
sweet child oh mine now while reacting
yeah you heard me say my favorite cover
of that is adam scott and catherine han
and their kids and step brothers though
the lyrics of this song reference again
again the imagery of uh blue eyes fresh
as a bright blue sky which i cannot help
but draw a connection with james gunn's
opening track for guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 mr blue sky also look at
the imagery here thor's eyes look way
bluer than they normally do something is
going on with him but stepping back from
that tonally this is absolutely a reset
for the character after avengers in game
and after the events of ragnarok
ragnarok completely changed the status
quo for every asgardian and now it looks
like thor is just retiring from his life
as a ruler of asgard and from being an
avenger he now just wants to be this
space pirate along with the guardians of
the galaxy well what draws him back into
it well we don't meet gore in this
trailer but we do see some evidence of
his crimes there's a shot of a giant
corpse in the mountain snow this is
actually directly from the comics this
is falagar the behemoth and it's part of
the god butcher arc by jason aaron this
is when thor is investigating all the
different gods across the universe who
have shown up slaughtered they're being
killed by gore now who is gore if this
is the first time you're watching a
thorough 4 video i'll give you a brief
recap gore is called gore the god
butcher he carries a sword called all
black the necrosword he wants to
slaughter all gods because when he
prayed to the gods to save him and his
family his family ended up dead so that
makes thor and all the other asgardians
and everyone else who has the ranking of
god in the universe a target that he
uses this sword to kill the sword is
super mystical super powerful in marvel
comics lore it is the sword that was
used to behead the celestial nowhere
that gave us that planet now we're not
sure where the power scale will be in
the mcu but why not make this sword
capable of killing the celestial we just
met the celestials and eternals and if
it could kill this giant mountainous
behemoth the more dangerous and scarier
they can make this weapon the better
this movie is going gonna be now you may
be asking why did they not put christian
bale gore the god butcher in this
trailer i would say i don't think this
teaser needs it i think we get enough of
a sense of the conflict we never have
the music shift to make that super
obvious but the clues are there i mean
maybe the exact look of christian bale
any effects work they're doing on his
appearance that might be why the
marketing for this movie has been
delayed but note that it's still coming
out july 2022 it is not being delayed in
its release window which i think is a
good sign now as i am falling more and
more in love with moon knight super
exciting news i just got a delivery of
the new moon berry hydration collector's
box from g-fuel inspired by marvel
studios series moon knight now streaming
on disney plus this bad boy comes with
the hydration tub and a 16-ounce shaker
cup both of which have moon night on
them let's try some out g-fuel
and just shaking it up
[Applause]
oh that's good so moonberry is a tasty
combination of blueberry and acai it's
got no calories and no sugar it's also
caffeine free which is nice if you're
consuming it at night or you've already
had your daily max of caffeine it's got
focused aminos antioxidants and it's got
an alphabet soup of vitamins to keep you
hydrated and laser sharp while you
search for easter eggs or if you game or
pursue some other passion so click the
link in the description or use code
rockstars 30 to get 30 off the
collector's box and again thanks to g
fuel for sponsoring this video cheers
now the trailer ends with a jane foster
wielding a reassembled mjolnir from the
shattered pieces that it was left as by
hella's destruction on the cliff side of
norway so somehow it has been pieced
back together now interestingly the
description of this movie on youtube
says jane foster natalie portman who to
thor's surprise
inexplicably wields his magic hammer
mjolnir as the mighty thor now taika
with tt a couple years ago said that
he's going to be adapting this from the
mighty thor comic run in which jane
foster becomes lady thor it's an amazing
comic run by jason aaron where jane
foster gets a cancer diagnosis and while
going through chemotherapy she ends up
wielding mjolnir and this is after
actually the god butcher storyline where
uh thor drops mjolnir he gives it up
because nick fury whispers something to
his ear uh something that we later find
out where the words gore was right which
so got under thor's skin that he made
him doubt his own worthiness his own
deity status so then the hammer ended up
in a way calling to jane foster and
every time jane foster would pick it up
it would power her up and it's been
confirmed by natalie portman that they
are adapting this cancer subplot into
the character the reason i focus so much
on the word inexplicably is uh it
implies that there was some kind of a
mysterious magic that involved the
reassembly of mjolnir a magic that thor
despite all of his encounters with
various kinds of magic does not
understand at all so what was that magic
a theory that i have loved is that it
could have been some kind of remnant of
the reality stone's effects on jane
foster from which she had the ether
pulsing through her veins obviously the
reality stone has been atomized in its
present form in the mcu but we know that
all these stones have some kind of
cosmic radiation effect on the world and
i think that effect may have been the
cause of her cancer but may have also
been the cause of her link with uh with
mjolnir now i think this movie is going
to introduce us to a lot of other gods
across the marvel universe there's a
shot of uh what looks like the olympiad
right like that's almost certainly zeus
holding up the uh the bolt so these
theories that russell crowe as zeus in
the movie look to be true oh i am going
to need to go back through the
background of all those colorful figures
to see who they could be but yeah i
think it's going to be an early target
for gore i think a lot of these people
are not going to make it out of the
movie alive obviously they don't want to
show us that yet in the trailer honestly
i was waiting for like the music to cut
out and one by one
but obviously that um that probably
would have spoiled too much for the
trailer i get it another reason why i
think this trailer and the marketing may
have been pushed a bit is to give titles
like moon knight an opportunity to
introduce the concept of other gods
existing in this universe because i
really do think the any ad of moon
knight have already been targeted or
will be targeted in the future by gore
but another reason i think why the
marketing might have been delayed a
reason why this trailer is a bit shorter
than you would expect is that there are
still some major plot implications that
marvel studios doesn't want us to know
yet until we're on the other side of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness in fact that inexplicably word
in the description may refer to some
multiverse mechanics the way wanda
maximoff the scarlet witch is going to
repave the marvel universe so that
certain types of folks are respawned in
this universe from being erased from it
in the past i'm talking mutants baby we
obviously don't see any mutants in this
trailer we might not see any mutants in
the movie but just the implications of
the world being rewritten might be very
important in the story and it could be
very important to where gore comes from
because gore with this axe to grind only
suddenly there's a couple different ways
you could look at it like maybe his
world was so screwed up by thanos snap
and specifically the avengers unsnapping
it returning everyone for the blip the
chaos that ensued on gore's planet could
have pissed him off there's mention of
what the eternals have done planet after
planet destroy an entire planet maybe
gore was from one of those worlds like
then i mentioned uh century six i always
liked the idea that that could have been
gore's home world or really could have
just been something from the multiverse
gore could have come from a universe
where his family was slaughtered and now
he's in this one but with that same
vengeance in his heart okay there's a
lot of fun stuff happening in this
trailer i gotta break it down frame by
frame so that video is gonna come out to
the channel tomorrow in the meantime be
sure to go to our merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com we still have some
of these uh moon knight latest obsession
shirts called tomb of the moon god
they're selling fast though follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow a
new rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you